friends and family of congressman john
lewis are gathering in atlanta
this morning for the funeral of the
civil rights icon former presidents
barack obama
george w bush and bill clinton along
with house speaker nancy pelosi
quite a distinguished lineup are set to
speak at the historic ebenezer baptist
church today
the church as you've heard has played a
key role in the civil rights movement
the reverend dr martin luther king jr
served as a co-pastor with his father
until his death in 1968 reverend rafael
warnock is now the senior pastor of the
church and will preside over this
morning ceremony he is also
a democratic candidate for the u.s
senate reverend good morning it's so
nice to see you this morning
listen the nation has been paying
tribute to the congressman
all week but today is a final farewell
and you are doing the honors
how would you describe what do you want
us to remember and how would you
describe your friend
good morning gail it's great to be here
with you
one of the great honors of my life has
been to serve as the senior pastor
to john lewis a true american patriot
who sacrificed it all because he
believed in the promise
of our american democracy and at the
heart of his activism
and his work as a public servant uh was
his faith and so
it's a it's fitting that we would be
here uh on this day
uh his work and his life's mission and
his perspective began
at church in troy alabama and
we're grateful to be with him and and
his family as he's crossed that final
bridge
into eternity yeah he walked people know
him say he walked and lived his faith
when did you all first meet for the
first time and what do you remember
about him
yes i i first met john lewis as a
student
at morehouse college some of the
students had planned a protest i was
president of the chapel assistance at
the martin luther king jr international
chapel on the campus of morehouse
college
and we invited some of the influencers
and leaders in our
community to join the students in the
protest we invited
city council persons and others john
lewis is the only one who showed up
he was a newly elected congressman i
remember how inspired we were as
students to hear his voice but we were
more inspired just by the the power of
his presence
uh this icon in american history yeah
you know reverend when you said showing
up
i said what that must mean to you to be
his pastor but you talked about him
showing up
we interviewed the clintons last week
and they said the thing that stood out
for them about john lewis is that
he was seemingly always there and he
always showed up hillary clinton tells a
story about him
showing up at a book signing at costco
and he said he just happened to be in
the neighborhood
that was who this man was
that's certainly who he was and history
will remember him because he
showed up in the places where it really
counts
he was just captured by this whole idea
of freedom it captured his imagination
the voice of martin luther king jr
caught his attention as a young man and
uh he reached out to dr king
and forever will his deeds be etched in
history but the thing that i want to
emphasize
is that at the heart of his activism
really was his faith a faith passed on
from enslaved ancestors and so when you
see a man stand up to jim clark
when you see someone go on a bridge
knowing that they are facing
violence and brutality he did that
because his faith
represented a kind of spiritual power
shaped by
suffering a moral audacity that
transcended human station
and called on human law to more closely
align itself with the law of love all of
us are better
because john lewis came our way as a
young man he wrestled with a call to
ministry
but instead of preaching sermons he in a
real sense became a sermon
reverend how was he able to do this with
no bitterness he talked
about being beaten he talked about
almost losing his life he had been
arrested several times
we often say he loved the country when
they didn't love him back and he had no
bitterness how was he able to do that
well you know he he often said that that
he didn't that well dr king used to say
that love is is too heavy a burden to
bear
and john lewis internalized that he
believed it
and here we are all of these days later
john lewis passed away almost a couple
of weeks ago
and there's so much going on in the news
cycle and yet a whole nation
pauses to remember him it's because he
wasn't a transactional politician he was
a transformational figure
who brought all that he could bring
to the promise of democracy he kept his
eye on the prize
i think he say to me all the time keep
your eyes on the prize yeah he left a
great lesson for all of us you know did
you see his op-ed this morning in the
new york times
that this is something that stuck out
when you see something that's not right
you must say something
you must do something democracy is not a
state
does an act in each generation must do
his part to help build what we called
a beloved community
i love that part that's john lewis
that's john lewis and we've got to keep
his work moving
forward a lot of folks are celebrating
him right now but the best way to honor
him really
is to reauthorize the voting rights act
that was his life's work and some of
those who celebrate him right now
are sitting on the voting rights act
they ought to pass it and honor this
true american patriot
a lot a lot of people are hoping that
happens thank you very much reverend
warnick we'll be thinking about you
today and watching thank you so much sir